Rob Riner who Meathead you know from All
in the Family uh Riner is making a
documentary on Christian nationalism and
Riner is an atheist and he's a big lib
and there's no doubt about that he has
said nice things about Christianity in
the past In fairness he said that he's
not a Christian but he tries to live
like a Christian he said that you know
love your neighbor as yourself is as
good a a maxim as he's ever heard so
he's attracted
to some kind kind of
uh single aspect of Christianity but he
doesn't even though he's attracted to
that it's an important rule he he does
not he's not sufficiently attracted to
embrace the whole faith in fact he seems
fairly opposed to the faith uh and he's
certainly opposed to the faith in
forming American politics and that
wouldn't be a big story libs are going
to make anti-christian movies they do it
all the time the bigger part of the
story is that
major Evangelical
leaders major Christian leaders at some
point or another have actually joined
Rob Riner in attacking Christian
nationalism we'll get to that in one
second first though we obviously
primarily want to store up our Treasures
in Heaven but when you want to supply
your own material needs on Earth for the
duration of your life you you'll
probably want some resources for that
which is why you got to check out Birch
gold right now text nolles to 98 9898
diversify your savings with physical
precious medals while stockpiling silver
in your home safe take advantage of
Birch gold group's most popular special
of the year now through December 22nd
for every $5,000 you spend with Birch
gold they will send you a 1 o Silver
Eagle Coin for free that's a pretty good
deal Tex NOS kW to 98 9898 to claim your
eligibility now you can purchase gold
and silver and have it shipped directly
to your home or have Birch Gold's
precious metal Specialists help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into a
tax sheltered IRA and gold for no money
out of pocket they will send you free
silver for every every $5,000 you
purchase keep it for yourself or give
something with real value as a stocking
stuffer this year just text the keyword
nolles kwes to 998 9898 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
happy customers now is the best time to
buy gold from Birch gold text nolles
kwes to 98 9898 claim your eligibility
for free silver un qualifying purchases
before December 22nd that is nolles kwes
to 98
9898 Rob Riner going after Christian
National ISM America and Christianity
are like baseball and apple pie and we
celebrate them
together I was 16 17 years old when I
became a Christian I'm an Evangelical
Minister I've been a Christian my whole
life I'm a Christian nationalist I have
nothing to be ashamed of because that's
what most Americans are is Christian B
Christian um no it is
isn't we should be blazing forth as a
countercultural example and instead
we're leading the charge of malice and
division Christian nationalism uses
Christianity as a means to an end that
end being some form of
authoritarianism being a Christian is
about the values of inclusion Christian
nationalism is certainly not based on
the values of the Gospel this is not a
movement about Christian values this is
about Christian
power okay I don't recognize anyone in
this movie other than David French who
is exactly the sort of person I would
expect to be in this movie David French
a former writer for National Review a
Libertarian or neoconservative minded uh
right-winger but he wrote for he wrote
for conservative Publications and he was
a member of conservative organizations
and then Trump I guess radicalized him
and now he's pretty clearly on the left
he was writing for the Atlantic for a
while now I think he's is writing for
the New York Times and his raise on debt
appears to be to attack from the from
the authority of an American Evangelical
a a conservative but not that kind of
conservative you know a court gester in
the Kingdom of liberalism from his his
uh self-styled identity as a
Conservative Christian he attacks
conservatives and he attacks Christians
now the reason I don't know any of the
other people in here and the only reason
I know David French is because he ran in
conservative circles for some time
is it this is all Protestants who are in
this movie there are no Catholics and
it's no knock on Protestants certainly
no knock on evangelicals many of my best
friends are evangelicals and Protestants
but I'm I'm not I'm a Catholic and so
I'm just not as familiar with these
leaders of the Evangelical movement
so why is that why is it that it's
evangelicals in this movie well it it's
no knock on evangelicals exactly it's
more to do with Christian nationalism
Christian nationalism is a fundamentally
Protestant
movement now in practice I support
Christian nationalism I and in practice
I guess David French and those those
evangelicals in this movie oppose
Christian nationalism the reason that I
support Christian nationalism
practically is because we have a nation
I respect our nation I'm a patriot love
my country it's an extension of filial
piety and and the soul of our nation is
Christian it was
founded explicitly as a Christian Nation
in 1620 by the pilgrims at Plymouth Rock
who sailed here on the Mayflower which
is the name of an excellent brand of
cigars and the uh leaders of the
Massachusetts Bay Colony called this a a
model of Christian charity a shining
city on a hill our founding fathers
spoke in broadly Christian terms John
Adams said that our Morality In America
would have to be a Christian morality
John Jay said exactly the same thing
George Washington gave thanks to God
Abraham Lincoln never wrote or spoke
without in some way channeling the King
James Bible we've got in God we trust on
our money it's a Christian country most
people are Christian it's just a
Christian country there's no other way
to put it so if we're a nation and we're
going to be Christian well I guess
that's Christian nationalism right but
the Liberals don't like that because the
Liberals don't like Christianity and
they don't like nation states what they
want is liberal globalism now the reason
I say Christian nationalism is
fundamentally Protestant is because
nationalism is fund M Ally Protestant
nationalism is a product of the West
failan system the Treaty of Augsburg and
the piece of West philia which put an
end to the religious wars which came
about as a result of the cracking up of
the unity of Christendom so before all
of that
happened Europe Christendom broadly was
United in one Faith with lots of
different political entities but there
was a connection between the unified
faith and all of the different political
entities notably the Holy Roman Empire
but even other little political entities
and therefore the civilization had a
Unity we all had the same faith and and
that Faith was expressed visibly in
political life because our faith is an
incarnational Faith because our Lord is
Incarnate he's not just floating in the
sky he enters into history in time and
space he picks specific Apostles he
gives them the keys to the kingdom of
heaven he says go forth and Make
Disciples of all Nations he says go feed
my sheep he says on this rock I will
build my Church Simon Peter you're now
Peter which means Rock he says these
things and then there's a visible
expression and the apostles go off to
all the corners of the World and St
Thomas makes it all the way to India and
Peter and Paul go to Rome and it it's a
you what separates Christianity from
other religious Traditions is
that you can trace it through journalism
you can you can trace it not just
through philosophy or abstract theology
but
with real people in real time and space
there's a there's an an Apostolic
succession going all the way back to our
Lord which means
that if you are
Christian you must believe that the
faith has some kind of physical
expression and a community expression
unfortunately though certain branches of
branches of sects of branches of modern
Christianity have ignored all of that
and they wanted just to abstract
everything about the faith and they want
to make religion something that you just
do in your own little head maybe quietly
at night in your room but that has no
visible expression anywhere but we can't
do that Christianity spreads as a
community and we because we're social
creatures because we're the political
animal even the very ability to pray
will expand or diminish based on
political circumstances do we live in a
culture that's conducive to prayer
that's conducive to the flourishing of
the religion or not don't forget
Christianity is not a it's not a
polytheistic religion okay our God is a
jealous God and we'll have no other gods
before
him so when you have people here saying
look I'm a Christian oh I'm a Christian
I love Christianity and everything but
Christian
nationalism is
not it's not Christian at all it's
opposed to Christianity it's
authoritarian what does that mean author
it certainly makes demands of you it
certainly gives a shape to public life I
would I wouldn't call that authoritarian
but yeah it's it's not liberal I guess
yeah that's true it's about power yeah
well there yeah there is I mean we think
that Jesus Christ is King of the
universe yeah there's power there yes
there's Authority what you bind on Earth
will be bound in heaven what you lose on
Earth will be Loos in heaven that
implies Authority yeah but it's not
liberal you're well there it is you've
hit the nail on the head and so this is
the question for the people in Rob
riner's movie This is the question for
David
French are you you first a Christian or
are you first a
liberal which is it many are going to
want to say well I'm both oh okay you
can serve two Gods you can serve two
masters you got to pick one which you
got which is it and there are many
people look I I don't mean to only
single out the Evangelical Protestants
there are many Catholics who think in
this way too though it's not a
traditionally Catholic way of thinking
which means that the FBI is not going to
investigate this way of thinking but
but
these these ideas in as much as they
conflict are going to require that we
choose one or the other which is it
which is it folks are we in a Christian
Nation or are we in a liberal globalist
hodg podge of just vague nothingness for
me if I got to pick one just a practical
reality I'll choose the former man that
was a great clip huh huh well now wait
wait you got to ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael N YouTube Channel we'll
see you next time